voilà on compte
bonsoir la durée sa vaillance et joey
starr fait la dame est inquiétant et
jérôme le banner bonsoir mon sens ça va
vous passez dans le quartier la whey ça
atteint lumière c'est bien vous êtes
bien ici alors joe et comment ça va on
partait rivoire jamel debbouze au casino
de paris hier soir ça ça vous a plu
pourrait subir ça ça vous a fait rire
assez ouais mais c'est une participante
jours allez je vous êtes monté sur scène
non non mon manager groupe a alors
jérôme le banner bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le numéro mondial de kahone le cas
one c'est de la boxe thaï pratiqué par
des gens assez assez corpulent alors se
rend souvent assez peu ça arrive alors
ce qu'on appelle des chiottes
ta phut ce terrien les chronos qui a
déclenché le boxeur ses pieds ses points
ses genoux c'est will rives souvent je
suis ceinture mais justement le cas one
donc ça c'est des arts martiaux
pratiqués par des gens de plus de 90 kg
vous dites c'est un sport violent c'est
animal ça sent le fauve dans l'arène
c'est vrai alors les participants
s'affrontent pendant toute l'année à
travers des épreuves éliminatoires
et puis en décembre il ya la finale des
huit meilleurs au japon la boue des
filets en europe puis en maillot
l'interview suicide
jérôme c'est un sport très populaire est
prise si tu savais qu'on avait presque
personne n'est pas des trucs incroyables
jeu c'est un sport qui est très
populaire dans le monde entier qui est
de plus en plus répandu en france même
si les médias en parlent pas beaucoup ça
peut on pas son passé vous apprenez les
grands sports en tennis ouais mais c'est
un grand sport à s'envoyer des gens qui
aiment bien on va regarder à quoi ça
ressemble